doesn't really matter if a protagonist
is active or passive I I think it does
I think nobody wants to watch a passive
character and even in real life if we I
guess there are some exceptions like
leaving Las Vegas where you had a
depressed alcoholic who said that was
his turn II and that's what the movie
was about and of course it was based on
a very well known book the but even like
a movie like Zelig where I guess it's a
character who's passive who's assuming
other characters personalities that are
other individuals personalities assuming
their identities that he's actively
doing that but most cases and then a
certain way I guess you could say in
leaving Las Vegas and Nicolas Cage
character was even though he's sitting
on a self a most of the time but he was
pretty committed and actively pursuing
drinking himself to death and dying in
Las Vegas he was committed to not
leaving Las Vegas I guess they think
that otherwise it's it's just boring and
even in with the writing of a script
it's best not to use passive verbs such
as he is being he is he you always want
to keep it active like he's walking it's
not like the sidewalks are passing him
by I but I feel that you always want to
have an active protagonist sometimes you
get scripts that are where they'll
change someone may change tenses you it
always has to be active present tense
talking again about like getting too
much advice to change a character even
though it's sort of like your central
journey and you're writing about it do
you think people layer it with other
parts of another care
because it's too close to home they
don't want to totally write their story
but the central message or value of the
film is a certain way but because they
don't really want to have it be their
own biopic really that they pepper in
these different things and it waters it
down so they make the protagonist a
female when it's really a man's journey
right Oh or a young man's coming-of-age
story no I think that come in it's
interesting because with the changing of
protagonist from a male to female I
understand that I mean if you take a
movie like speed it did work that it was
a female but you could have reversed the
sexes and it could have worked the movie
that Sandra Bullock did with not too
long ago it was originally I think
written as a role for George Clooney and
they changed it to a female I'm not
adverse to that at all and I've had
instances where I might have where I've
done that and sometimes it might been
this a white lead and you can make it an
african-american character or a
latin-american character and that's fine
and that's fresh you know to not have to
you so there are times when it can be
really really great and improve the
story but it's when a person is
compromising the the essence and spirit
of what they are connecting with and
it's fine to I mean I've done true
stories where we couldn't use the actual
characters names so we might have
changed the their profession so if one
was a computer engineer maybe we made
him a real estate agent or if the story
took place in Connecticut we changed it
to Colorado things like that are fine
but it's you don't you want to always
have a connection with the true essence
and spirit of the story and you accord I
go back to that word for me it's a core
vision of something that moves Ewing and
compels you and is a really strong story
that you want to tell
and at the heart of it is usually a it
might be an image that triggers
something or usually a character with
what I call a strong emotional want that
I had mentioned you a right we talked
about that I feel like I'm always
learning from respected colleagues and
associates and there's a screenwriter
who I really really respect and he was
the one who had we can talk about
motivation
I love with his phrase was that every
character that you become engaged with
especially protagonist in almost every
great film has this a character with a
very strong emotional want and need and
actually another book that I love
Stanislavski an actor prepares
he gives backstory for what the actor
needs to do before entering a scene and
he talks about a character having a
super objective which is the grand
overriding life objective and then the
immediate objective so maybe the big
objective is I want to be retired and
live in the Bahamas my immediate
objective I need to get this job
promotion or I mean just from this you
could have different genres immediately
I can tell you that the different
immediate objective is that he wants to
kill the man he works for
and get his money and steal his money so
two totally different movies with when
you change what the immediate objective
is and the super objective thinking to
when you talk about books an adaptation
I love is White Oleander oh yeah Janet
it was really oh my gosh amazing film
and and book as well if you were to
change Alice and Loehmann's character to
a male it seems like then you would have
to change all of the foster parents to
men as well because it was a it was a
relationship between the mother and
daughters right how toxic that was and
it does create different dynamics I
think also because that was
source material a really well-respected
book and a best-seller that you wouldn't
change it and there probably wouldn't it
if it wasn't based on the best-selling
book you could go other way but there
are two different stories and I think
again ever if it was a screenwriter or
the author what is truest to what's
getting you going what is inspiring you
is it you know dynamics between a mother
and daughter are different than between
a father and son so I think it's really
connecting as a writer when I say core
vision another way to describe it is the
source of inspiration the thing that
gets you really excited about the story
what is the journey you want to tell
right into for the motivation of all
those mothers whether it was Michelle
Pfeiffer's character mm-hmm and then all
of the you know Renee Zellweger had her
own um you know motivation mm-hmm and
and and Robin Wright's care it was so
they all had these interesting
motivations yeah very much yeah and
that's I think it's important for
screamers to really I think we can never
take for granted not knowing our
characters well enough now if it's
purely an action film like a speed it's
not so important to the ride is the
movie the or the mummy the original one
the it's there are motivations clearly
and a strong plot but it's really less
about deep character development but
anytime you're doing if it's generally
speaking if it's a psychological
thriller family drama comedy you need to
not take for granted that you can't know
your characters and a lot of writers
don't go through that step of really
knowing them and immersing themselves in
that character or characters I mean and
it comes up with like who are they what
you know where are they when that the
movie starts are they in a happy place
are they in a sad place did they just
break up with a boyfriend you are they
on
top of the world did they just get fired
these so knowing those kinds of things
and I apply what Stanislavski said which
is what is their super objective what do
they want
in life so to go through all of those
things is there even if it's not in the
script is there a pivotal thing that
happened that damaged them so those
types of things I usually give clients
I'm working with the character
questionnaire to help unleash all those
things about their character I so
because you can't really write from an
abstract place just oh he's a guy I like
that the questionnaire that's great
you